French bullies are looking for a dead
body in ivorian Mance as he saw while
crossing the Alps from Italy with Border
Police pushing back hundreds of refugees
and migrants every day it's forced them
to resort to a more dangerous route but
many attempts failed due to bad weather
and police patrolling in the mountains
using drones those pushed back returned
to a shelter run by an Italian priest I
heard there is someone it's the idea
defend someone die in the mountain but
so
yeah I'm so sorry for all of this but
since but it doesn't stop you yeah it
doesn't self stop you it will stop
something like this stop me
I mean is planning to live the same
evening using a route he downloaded from
an app
the shelter can barely cope with the
large number of people from Africa and
the Middle East arriving every day
more people arriving needs more people
to take care of and we can't give them
the attention they need if there are
fewer people we can talk to them and
give them some hope but when there are
100 people here we can just give them
some pasta a shower and a bed
the shelter provides warm clothes to
help them cope with often freezing
temperatures Amin left Morocco two years
ago and has faced violence traveling on
the so-called Balkan route from Turkey
we need a better life we come here to to
change the my life we don't come here to
we have food in Morocco we have
everything but we need better life
their Journey Through the Alps can see
them passing Peaks as high as 2 000
meters it's a difficult and sometimes
dangerous route but those Crossing have
been traveling for months and even years
to reach this point and have seen much
more dangerous situations
a prayer before the Journey Begins Amin
wants to go to Paris to start working in
food delivery but he'll need to cross
the Alps first
he gets separated from the others and
will now have to make the 8 to 10 hour
hike alone
a message the next morning he has made
it we meet him in France the journey was
much more difficult than he expected it
was so tired so tired it's not easy and
we were when I start
I talk with myself I tell you why I go
to check this way for it for for what
for this for money it's not it's not
good
would you do it again it's my life I I
risk in my life you know it's dangerous
he quickly tries to get to Paris to
start his new life expectations are that
in the coming months many more will
cross these mountains not knowing what
their future will hold stop fasten Al
Jazeera in brianson